Kanye West You gopher face Deutsche back
this week Kanye went on a media
Blitzkrieg he threw So Many Stones at
the Jews he's now an honorary General in
the West Bank which is soon to be the
only bank that will accept him yeah JP
Morgan actually canceled his account so
the only transaction Kanye is going to
have is when Caitlyn drops off the kids
so what exactly did yay say well hungry
hungry Hitler went on drink Champs with
the most bloated cheeks I've ever seen
on a human the guy looks like a ninja
turtle just had a root canal and
proceeded to spout off more hate than a
West Virginia water fountain he claimed
George Floyd was killed by fentanyl
wrong Kanye we have video evidence of a
throat getting crushed and don't worry
Kim's not in it he blamed the Jews for
trying to silence him yay the only Jew
that's ever kept your mouth shut was the
dentist that wired your jaw and of
course he defended his new shirt by
taking more shots at black lives matter
than Kyle Rittenhouse himself now I hear
some people saying Kanye did bring up
some very strong wrong points yes these
points that's it Kanye isn't the free
thinker he claims to be he hasn't had a
unique idea his entire life he just
regurgitates the talking points to the
latest pseudo-intellectual leech around
him the only original thoughts Kanye's
ever had are Amber Kim and Julius so hmm
is Kanye insane I don't know I don't
think there's a mental illness that
makes you a Nazi outside of Mel Gibson's
ex-wife that being said selfishly I hope
he is I'd rather believe this is the
behavior of a guy battling bipolar
disorder then except I've been
supporting a Black Skinhead for decades
so my message to you chipmunk cheeks is
simple
get better better friends better
therapists better perspective on the
world and better meds and good luck
because you're gonna need it
[Music]